[Musique]
le budget de la justice a augmenté
uniquement pour pallier un quinquennat
de sous investissement il ne s'agit là
que d'un rattrapage est pas du tout d'un
investissement réel dans la justice de
notre pays est le pire c'est que les
moyens affectés à la justice n'ont pas
été effectivement dépensés entre 2017 et
2020 chaque année près de 400 millions
d'euros n'ont tout simplement pas été
utilisé pour la justice avec des
tribunaux qui se retrouvent avec des
effectifs réels qui sont bien
inférieures aux effectifs théoriques
la france est à la traîne en moyenne et
rapporté au nombre d'habitants la france
dépense deux fois moins dans ces
tribunaux que l'allemagne enfin comment
se féliciter de l'augmentation du budget
quand la justice est totalement noyé
sous les procédures et que le
désarmement pénale entamée par
christiane taubira est évidemment
poursuivi par emmanuel macron eric
dupond-moretti fait des ravages une
amende pénale sur deux n'est pas
recouvrée et une peine de travaux
d'intérêt général sur cinq n'est pas
appliquée avec valérie pécresse nous
déploierons des moyens exceptionnels
pour améliorer le fonctionnement de nos
tribunaux et de notre justice avec un
grand plan orsec pour la justice qui
consacrera 9 milliards d'euros aux
tribunaux et aux prisons
[Musique]